um I just want to start with what Paul
Scully was saying I thought he spoke
quite powerfully actually about the
comments that were made by Prince
William's Grandma godmother he said that
it was an example of casual racism do
you think it was yeah I think he is and
I just paid tribute to Paul I thought he
spoke very bravely about his own
personal experiences there and that can
be very difficult to speak about one's
personal experiences I think it is an
example of casual racism and I think as
I understand I just only saw the news
breaking tonight uh as I understand it
palaces have you know moved this
individual on quite rightly so
there is a lot of casual racism in
society and we always have to stand firm
against it I was struck by that this
week because we have the census results
out this week and I represent Leicester
we're very proud of our diversity in
Leicester and Leicester is a a city with
a majority ethnic population and I was
very struck by the tone of some of the
language from some prominent people
actually around
which are making comments about cities
like Leicester and Birmingham in
response to this census state are there
any comments that you were particularly
important I mean I think they were I
mean I don't want to name individuals
because it's been videos but I mean it's
just a way in which there were sort of
suggestions I thought particularly on
social media that somehow that Leicester
was
and Christian or else or something like
that I think things like that and
um
I'm immensely proud of the rich
diversity of a city like Leicester I
think it and I think it strengthens us
as a city where a dynamic city today
because of our diversity I imagine that
the same would be the case in Birmingham
and other parts of the country and I
think we should always celebrate that
diversity but it is a it was a sad
reminder that there is still casual
racism out there and we have to stand
firm against it yeah exactly I think it
feels like it's sort of two kind of
examples of that I guess some would say
that
is there a blurring sometimes of the
Casual relations that you're talking
about and other concerns about
immigration
look
you know I mean people who will have
always have legitimate concerns about
immigration because they'll always have
legitimate concerns about
you know economic circumstances and
whether whether the economy is growing
sufficiently in order to ensure good
decent good decent well-paying jobs for
everybody so it's understandable that
people will have concerns about
immigration and that's why you've got to
have an immigration system which
responds to your economic needs which is
why we've said we need a points-based
system we know that there are gaps in
the labor market but what I would also
say and I'll say a little bit about this
earlier this week actually when you've
got increasing numbers of people leaving
the labor market employment is lower
today than it was pre-pandemic there's
more more over 50s leaving the labor
market there's actually more and more
people forced out of work for reasons of
ill health two and a half million the
highest for 20 years it's costing us 8
billion extra a year a year we actually
need schemes initiative measures to
support people to return to work and one
of my big big preoccupations is to get
Britain back to work and put in place
the measures to help people so I'm I was
saying let's devolve more employment
support to local area because they know
that they they know what's needed in
their area let's better link up the
employment system the employment support
system with with the NHS let's reform
our job centers because they're not
working as the valued Public Service in
every Community like they should do to
get the over 50s back to work to give
support for those who are out of work
for reasons of sickness when they need
it so there's big reforms that we've
been putting forward this week to
improve our economy
um I was also talking to Mr Scully about
strikes because of course we have 10 000
ambulance workers now um obviously a
very stressful very high pressure Job
saying that they are going to strike
because they want their pay to reflect
inflation would you like to see
inflation matching pay rises in the
public sector well I mean as you know I
led on health for labor party for what
felt like 100 years
um so I understand that NHS staff
whether it's paramedics or nurses or
Healthcare assistants or under the most
considerable strain and have been asked
to do more and more with less than less
over many years now for 12 years and
they face very tight pay packets wage
squeezes for many years I think the
trade unions who represent the health
workers will need to negotiate and
that's why it's incumbent upon the
health secretary not just to say oh my
door is open but to actually say right
let's get around the table let's see if
we can hammer out a deal because it's
not just about pay it's also about rotor
gaps it's also about safe Staffing my
question was about payday right yeah
your question was do you think that
workers in the NHS should get inflation
matching payment well they should get a
they should get a fair pay settlement
what does that mean I mean everyone
would say they should get off that but
what is the thing but let me matching
inflation but let me give you an example
here the government will have modeling
of what is Affordable now the government
Minister say no it's not a photo it's
not affordable but they've also they're
not giving you the full picture because
they're not taking into account how many
NHS staff are claiming Universal Credit
to top up their wages low paid NHS staff
will be getting Universal Credit so even
though on the one hand the government
will be saying we can't give of your pay
rise but on the other hand they're just
topping up their wages with Universal
Credit the taxpayer is still paying so I
it's not a cop-out the government will
have access to all that modeling okay
it's not a cop-out but I am really
unclear and I think most people would be
quite unclear listen because because I
you know in a negotiation it's not it's
not helpful for a politician who hasn't
got access to all that Dynamic model
it's just pick a number out of thin air
and say it should be X or it should be y
the government know how many how much
how many what is Affordable they'll also
know what their modeling is for what
they will get back in tax because
obviously nurses and paramedics will be
paying National Insurance and income tax
and they'll also have modeling for how
many are claiming Universal Credit all
those factors need to be taken into
account one thing that would help make
things more affordable is raising the
state pension age a male stride your
opposite number at the department for
which work and pension said that there's
a review Interstate retirement age
considering the cost of taxpayers and
intergenerational fairness as well as
life expectancy what's your view on
raising the retirement age well we
always have reviews every so often
they're periodic and that's always been
the case throughout throughout the
throughout the recent history of the
state of pension age and when these
periodic reviews will look to the
evidence and and they are usually
independent reviews when they've made
independent recommendations we have gone
along with that but there has to be an
import the review has to be allowed to
take place and politicians shouldn't
preempt it it's also now got to take
into account things like life expectancy
because the Assumption has been that
life expectancy would improve and indeed
life expectancy has improved since since
the war but life expectancy has begun to
stall but that's why we have an
independent review process and we'll see
what that independent review process
reports upon we shouldn't be
politicizing that independent review
process because the public finances are
in such a mess because of 12 Years of
the of lackluster growth and the you
know the recent disastrous budget about
two months ago now which
the economy it has to be a proper
process okay thank you very much for
being on the program because talk good
to have you in the studio
on the street it's always always a treat
thank you